invité de ce journal donc le ministre
des affaires européennes pierre
moscovici bonsoir bonsoir alors l'euro
bouleversé les clivages traditionnels
gauche droite est ce que le monde
politique ne va pas se recomposer qui
fait de l'europe autour de nouvelles
alliances
ça fait longtemps qu'ils aient des
divisions sur l'europe et c'est vrai
qu'elle traverse un peu les différents
camps à gauche on savait depuis
longtemps que les communistes ou le
monde et citoyens n'étaient pas emballés
par l'euro ça ne les empêche pas d'être
démontre parfaitement actif et solidaire
de la majorité mais ce qui est plus
particulier comme c'est ce qui s'est
passé au vert perd parce que ils
viennent quand même de changer trois
fois deux positions deux jours au départ
il sait comme le parti du président et
chirac leur a dressé la feuille de route
c'est l'euro et puis hier ils voulaient
voter nous ils se sont rendu compte que
ça faisait un peu désordre que ça
donnait l'impression d'être contre le
président et voilà les voilà qui tique
l'assemblée en s'abstenant après avoir
redit qu'ils refusaient tout en zone
motion de censure au nom de l'opposition
mais sans que l'une d'elles soit au
courant on compte s'y retrouvent plus
vraiment beaucoup avaient finalement
parce qu'on a parlé moi du nom des
communistes que des lunes changement de
stratégie du rer
vous savez c'est pas choquant ce qui se
passe à gauche
on le savait nous avions passé un
contrat avec les français nous les
socialistes nous avions dit nous mettons
quatre conditions à l'euro vouloir
rééquilibrer la construction européenne
nous savions que le parti communiste
n'était pas encore une fois très
favorable à l'euro nissan est le
mouvement des citoyens n'étaient pas
pour donc tout ça ne surprend pas
c'était attendu
en revanche le déchirement de
l'opposition notamment l'attitude du rpr
dont on se demande s'il est encore le
parti du président ou si le premier
souci de philippe seguin n'est pas au
contraire de déstabiliser le président
la république ça j'avoue que c'est plus
inattendu
je ne crois pas que ce soit du meilleur
effet effectivement les communistes
souhaitent toujours un référendum sur la
monnaie unique pourquoi l'exclure alors
que depuis maastricht qui a eu le traité
d'amsterdam le pacte le fameux pacte de
stabilité
pour une raison simple c'est que les
français ont déjà voté en 92 ils ont
voté pour le référendum sur le traité de
maastricht en hôtellerie majorité
attendait ya eu le pacte de stabilité
mais pas de s'inviter des guerres que
l'application d'une des boîtes alité de
maastricht en fait tout était déjà dans
le référendum sur le traité de
maastricht amsterdam vient devant nous
nous verrons comment ça va être ratifiée
moi je suis plutôt pour la voie
parlementaire parce que je crois qu'un
référendum sur la question européenne
justement dans ce climat d'un
habilité politique dans ce climat de
déstabilisation des différentes forces
et notamment de la droite qui là dessus
est également en train d'exploser avec
la montée du front national ça n'est pas
très sain je crois que ça risquerait de
ressusciter toute l'épreuve française
on ferait payer à l'europe au fond tous
les malaises de la société
non c'est un trait des techniques
amsterdam ratifions le par la voie
parlementaire leur parlant des élections
européennes à présent qu auront lieu
l'an prochain le mode de scrutin va être
modifié le figaro parlé hier de 13
grandes régions
vous confirmez moi j'ai proposé cette
modification parce que je crois qu'il
faut que les députés européens soient
plus identifiables par les gens moi je
l'étais parlement européen on savait pas
comment on été élu en fait on n'est ni
chaud ni ce national fait pas bon il
faut rapprocher les députés européens
des gens fait donc il vaut mieux
effectivement avoir des grandes régions
alors j'ai fait une suggestion qui est
pour ne pas compliquer les choses de
regrouper les régions actuelles de m par
exemple la bretagne et les pays de loire
ou de mettre les deux normandies
ensemble de m nord pas de calais la
picardie de mettre la bourgogne et la
franche-comté qui est ma région ensemble
voilà ce que je propose ça pourrait
faire 10 11 ça peut faire 13 je crois
que ce qui est important c'est
effectivement qu'on puisse savoir pour
qui on vote
c'est la seule façon d'ailleurs de
réconcilier les français avec l'europe
les élections européennes sont comme
l'élection on vote le moins
et moi je le tiens à ce qu'on aime
l'europe parce que le road show
populaire et pour ça il faut aussi que
les députés européens soient un peu plus
connus merci pierre moscovici le d le
débat à l'assemblée a donc été marquée
par le changement de stratégie du rpr ce
soir notre dessinateur l'on insiste sur
cette actualité et sur la motion de
censure déposée par le rpr contre le
gouvernement
la mission